- Do it, I welcome death.
- [Josh Allen narrating:] As far back as April of 2018, I always wanted to be a Buffalo Bill.
[Allen:] Bills Mafia! Haha, hey, I’m just happy to be here.
- [Allen narrating:] The Bills Mafia did what they wanted.
- [Allen:] OWWWW. I HOPE THIS GOES VIRAL.
[Allen narrating:] There was Single Tary.
- What can I say, I can’t be tied down!
- [Allen narrating:] Tre the Killer.
- I took care of that duck for ya.
- [Allen narrating:] Dead Ed Oliver.
Little Stevie Kicks.
- Here’s the kicker: ME!
- [Allen narrating:] J. Cole Beasley.
- My name's Cole Beasley, and I’m here to say
I like to rap in a very white way!
- [Allen narrating:] Our coach, Seany McDerm Derm.
- Hey, you boys having fun?
Don’t, OK? Culture change.
- [Allen narrating:] And then there was the Gorefather.
- I'll make him an offer he can't refuse.
COME UP TO NEAR-CANADA AND PLAY ICE FOOTBALL.
BEING WARM IS FOR CHILDREN.
- [Allen narrating:] We whacked our opponents the old-fashioned way:
with defensive football that was super boring.
- OH GOD, MILES.
- Leave the ball, take the wings.
- Sauce...so...hot...
- Actually, let’s leave him alone.
- ENJOY YOUR MEAL, SIR!
- [Allen narrating] And now we’re on the run.
- [Allen:] Good thing I think I’m a running quarterback!
- HEY, YOU.
YEAH, ALL FREAKIN’ HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOU FLIPPIN' LISTEN TO ME.
I’m P.O.’d about the M.F.ing lurkers watching our B.S.
So subscribe to this G.D. channel or G.T. the Fluff O.
DADDY SAYS SUBSCRIBE.